oh my God that'd be such an inside bit
what what if we joined the next crater
clash and we hype it up like we're gonna
[__] kill each other right away yeah
as soon as we walk in dude oh my God
both of our coaches just stand up and
throw the towels we walk through the
center of the Ring
hey thank you yeah yeah yeah dude you
are a Class Act bro you're a Class Act
love you man love you everyone's like oh
yeah sorry I got scared no I have with
you sorry it's like a panic attack yeah
it's like very different from telling
jokes I didn't I didn't think it'd be
that different what happened to you out
there
I got a little scared
I just didn't want to get punched well
what happened out there my Eczema it's
starting to I don't know it's just kind
of flaring up inside the rap so like I
think I just need to leave you think
you'll get in the ring again no no
not too scary yeah
and I'm really itchy yeah